tenemos un circuito interesante por aquí
y el objetivo de este vídeo es encontrar
cuál es la corriente que fluye por esta
resistencia de 6 oms pausa el vídeo e
intenta responderlo por tu cuenta bien
la forma en la que voy a resolverlo será
la siguiente primero voy a simplificar
el circuito tomaremos estas dos
resistencias que están en paralelo y
pensaremos en cuál es la resistencia
equivalente esto ya lo hemos visto antes
1 entre la resistencia equivalente es
igual a 1 entre 6.0 oms + 1 entre 12.02
ahora un sexto es igual a 212 ambos por
lo tanto esto es lo mismo que 212 amos
masondo xiabo lo cual es 3 12 ambos y 3
doceavos es lo mismo que uno entre 4.0
ops
y si uno entre la resistencia
equivalente es igual a un cuarto de homs
eso significa que la resistencia
equivalente es de 4 oms entonces podemos
simplificar el circuito de tal manera
que reemplazaremos estos dos circuitos
en paralelo con una resistencia que
tiene un valor equivalente de 42 ahora
el siguiente paso es encontrar la
corriente que pasa por esta parte del
circuito que es lo mismo que la
corriente que pasa por aquí y podemos
llamarla y subíndice 1 para eso podemos
usar la ley de ohm que nos dice que el
subíndice 1 es igual a nuestra caída de
voltaje que es 24 volts entre la
resistencia equivalente de estas dos
resistencias en serie y para encontrar
la resistencia equivalente de
resistencias en serie simplemente tienes
que sumarlas por lo tanto esto será
igual a 2.0 ohms más 4.0 oms
24 entre 2 + 4 que es lo mismo que 24
entre 6 que es igual a 4 como trabajamos
con dos cifras significativas me quedara
4.0 y como hablamos de corriente serán
4.0 amperes ahora como usaremos esta
información para calcular la corriente
que pasa por aquí bueno podemos llamarla
y subíndice 2 una forma de resolverlo
sería preguntarnos por la caída de
voltaje que tendremos de este punto a
este punto ya que si conocemos esa caída
de voltaje de este punto a este punto
entonces ya podremos conocer la caída de
voltaje que hay de aquí a aquí y con
esto ya conocemos cuál es la caída de
voltaje de este punto hasta el final así
que hagámoslo la caída de voltaje en
esta primera resistencia recuerda el
cambio en el voltaje es igual a la
intensidad de corriente eléctrica por la
resistencia así que en este caso
tendremos una corriente eléctrica de 4
amperes
la resistencia que es de 2 oms lo que
nos dará 8.0 volts por lo tanto la
diferencia de voltaje entre este punto y
este otro es de 24 volts lo que sabemos
por esta fuente de voltaje pero si
disminuimos 8 volts de este punto a este
otro entonces la diferencia entre este
punto y este otro o dicho de otra manera
el voltaje que pasa entre este punto y
el otro será una caída de 16 volts
nuestra deltaven a través de la
resistencia es de 16 volts y con ello
podemos usar de nuevo la ley de ohm para
encontrar y subíndice 2 porque y
subíndice 2 va a ser igual a la caída de
voltaje que son 16 volts entre el valor
de la resistencia que son 6 oms y esto a
que es igual bueno
16 entre 6 es igual a 2 enteros y 4
sextos o 2 enteros y dos tercios o 2 606
y si redondeamos a dos cifras
significativas
tengo 27 amperes y con esto ya logramos
encontrar lo que buscábamos esta
corriente es de 2.7 amperes pero podemos
seguir analizando todo esto a manera de
diversión de encargo que encuentres cuál
es el valor de la corriente y su vílchez
3 esta de aquí para eso puedes usar la
misma técnica una de las cosas con las
que debes sentirte cómodo es que la
corriente que fluye en esta primera
resistencia es de 4 amperes y ésta se
divide entre y subirse 2 e iu subíndice
3 por lo tanto y subíndice 2
y subir c 3 se suman para obtener los 4
amperes originales así que pensando en
esto si hacemos el mismo tipo de
análisis para ir subíndice 3 obtendremos
1.3 samper es porque 2.7 + 1.3 amperes
es igual a 4 amperes y ya con esto hemos
acabado nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo